the movie opens in 1994 in Long Beach
California where a woman named Aaron
guell is appointed to teach English to
some atrisk students at woodro Wilson
High School despite its past Acclaim the
school standards have declined due to
enforced voluntary integration
furthermore the racial tension has
heightened since the Los Angeles riots 2
years prior on the first day Aaron who
appears very excited to teach gets
dressed in red and leaves for school she
enters the classroom and waits for the
students to arrive shortly after they
enter the class but begin engaging in
their own discussion disregarding the
fact that there's a teacher next to them
Aaron tries to initiate the course study
but the students aren't ready to listen
not long after two boys in the class get
into an argument which soon escalates
when Aaron is not able to control them
she walks outside and gets some help to
separate them during the lunch break she
notices that the school is divided into
numerous groups based on their tribes
and each group is the Rival of the other
despite this Aaron attempts to instill
respect but they ignore her and continue
to be disruptive in class A few days
later a Hispanic student named Eva
Benitez lets her boyfriend Paco into the
school along with his fellow gang
members soon after the alarm Bell Rings
prompting several students to charge out
and fight on the school grounds the
situation eventually gets intense while
Aaron Witnesses all of it being helpless
that evening she returns home upset and
confides everything in her husband's
Scot she hopes that her father does not
watch the news because he is already
against her decision of teaching the
atrisk students one night Eva goes into
a convenience store while Paco and two
other friends stay in the car at the
same time Eva's classmate and rival
named Cindy neor who is a Cambodian
Refugee enters the same store along with
her two friends inside an
African-American student named Grant
rice who is playing an arcade game gets
frustrated about losing and demands a
refund from the store owner however this
only infuriates the owner who orders him
to leave the store as Grant storms out
Paco holds him at gunpoint intending to
kill him as retaliation for losing a
fight against him earlier he opens fire
but misses and accidentally kills one of
Cindy's friends Grant flees the scene
but he is later arrested for the
homicide in the aftermath Eva being an
eyewitness must testify in court in
order to guard her own group and to
protect her boyfriend he puts the blame
on Grant identifying him as the shooter
the following day at school a student
named Tito draws a racist drawing and
passes it among his friends to mock a
classmate named Jamal when Aaron notices
this she uses the drawing to teach them
about the Holocaust however none of the
students seem to know what that is in
the midst of their discussion Eva
expresses her hatred towards white
people because they have no respect for
how they live and they only want respect
as if they deserve it for free air
encounters emphasizing that one must
give respect before for expecting it in
return however Eva asserts that white
people can do anything for their pride
she reveals how she saw the white cops
shooting her friend in the back just for
reaching into his pocket she also claims
how she has seen the white officers
break into her house and take away her
father for no reason another student
named Marcus adds that they are ready to
die protecting their own tribe because
they can at least die with respect after
hearing all of this Aaron clears their
misconception highlighting the reality
that after they die they'll simply be
buried in the ground and will be
forgotten it won't matter whether they
were an original gangster or not somehow
I don't think an existential crisis is
going to improve these kids' moods after
class Aaron approaches the department
head Margaret Campbell and requests to
provide the students with the books with
which they can relate however the head
refuses to do so as she knows that
they'll only damage the books and lose
them moreover the school doesn't have
the budget to buy new books every
semester instead she tells Aaron to
focus on teaching them discipline and
obedience unable to persuade her Aaron
goes to talk to another faculty member
named Brian much to her disappointments
he also aligns with the department head
and believes that integration is a lie
he claims that those who want to study
should not suffer due to those who are
unwilling or shouldn't even be studying
there despite this setback Aaron vows to
reform her students to achieve this she
has them play a game called The Line
Game in which she asks some question
questions instructing them to walk up to
the line if they ever have been in such
a situation she starts with some basic
questions such as how many of you like
Snoop Dog's album and other borderline
racist generalizations at one point she
comes up with a serious question how
many of you have lost friends due to
intert tribe fights in response all of
the students walk up to the line which
makes them realize what they're doing in
addition to this game she also provides
them with some notebooks asking them to
write anything they want to express
after class Aaron goes through
everyone's notebooks in which they have
written about their past heart-wrenching
accounts of being evicted being abused
and seeing their loved ones die these
Revelations make her feel really bad and
as a result she intends to take the
matter into her own hands Aaron then
decides to take on two part-time jobs
one as a hotel concierge and the other
as a departmental storkeeper in order to
pay for more books and extracurricular
activities for the students she also
appeals to Dr con a School director to
persuade Margaret to give her a chance
as the days pass by Aaron starts to
spend a lot more time at school much to
the disappointments of her husband he
tells her that he is upset because she
didn't even consult him about her new
jobs and that he doesn't understand her
intention working the part-time jobs to
pay for another job however she promises
that it is temporary and she will get
back to her normal life once her
students grades have improved one day
Aaron manages to get permission to take
the students on a field trip trip to the
Museum of Tolerance there they get to
know more about the history of the
Holocaust along with the issues like
bullying and hate crimes after an entire
day of exploration Aaron brings all of
them to the restaurant where she works
for dinner there she appears to have
invited several Jewish Holocaust
Survivors to talk with the students
regarding their tragic past experiences
all of these efforts eventually begin to
change the mentality of the students
they start to realize that being Rivals
against each other just based on color
should not be a reason to prohibit their
friendships with one another meanwhile
her unique training methods are scorned
by her fellow faculty members as well as
the department head the next school year
begins and Aon teaches the same class
again making it the second year that
she's their teacher on the first day she
makes her class propose a toast for
change allowing everyone to open up
about their struggles and what they wish
to change about themselves this leads
everyone to know about each other's life
problems which Fosters deeper
connections among the students
strengthening their friendships in the
ensuing days Aaron provides them with a
book about Anne Frank hoping that they
can all relate to it as the students
start reading it they learn Anne was a
german-born Jewish girl who kept a diary
in which she described life in hiding
under Nai persecution the students also
come to know about a woman named Meep
geese who did a courageous work of
helping Anne Frank her family and some
other Dutch Jews hide from the Nazis
during the war knowing that Meep geiz is
still alive the students request Aaron
to bring her to their school and share
her story with them Aaron is hesitant
because Meep geese is now an elderly
woman and also because bringing her to
the United States would be very
expensive however the students insist
and even promise to raise the funds for
it themselves starting from the very
next day all the students conduct
various fundraising activities such as
organizing Beach food stalls dance
programs and other entertaining events
with all their Collective efforts they
managed to gather the required funds in
a few days amidst this Aaron also makes
her best efforts to reach Meep geese and
manages to invite her as an honorable
guest the anticipated day arrives as
Meep gize finally Graces the school with
her presence bringing immense Joy to the
students Marcus escorts her to the hall
where students gather to hear her
wartime experiences she recounts facing
the Nazis with courage even when
confronted with a gun to her head at one
point Marcus who is moved by her story
stands up and tells her that she is his
hero however she humbly rejects the
title insisting that she was merely
doing the right thing Meep also
persuades the students that they are all
heroes and that with their own small
ways they can turn on a small light in a
dark room inspired by the events Marcus
decides to reconcile with his past here
it is revealed that he had abandoned his
mother to join a violent gang now that
he has realized his mistake he returns
home and apologizes to his mother
expressing his wish to change once and
for all on the other hand Grant's trial
near and Eva's mother asks her if she
knows what to say in the court at this
point Eva grapples with a moral dilemma
whether to do the right thing or protect
her tribe by giving false testimony
ultimately at the trial she ends up
listening to her heart and shocks the
entire courtroom by revealing that Paco
is the one who killed Cindy's friend and
not Grant with this testimony the
innocent guy is spared while Paco is
convicted however Eva's actions
obviously have consequences the very
following day she's attacked by her own
group members who threaten her but she
is ultimately spared because of her
father's contribution towards the tribe
in the aftermath of this event Eva moves
in with her aunt for safety in the next
scene Aaron returns home only to
discover that Scott has packed his bags
to leave while dedicating her entire
time to the students she seems to have
left her personal life behind Scott
believes what she is doing is Noble work
but he also expresses that he can't stop
feeling lonely as a result of this he
bids her a final goodbye and departs
leaving her devastated back at school
Aaron informs her students that they
will soon be promoted to their junior
year they ask if she will be teaching
them to which she answers in the
negative she tells them that she isn't
allowed to take the junior classes as
per the school rules hearing this the
students protest demanding that they
need her on their request Aaron has a
meeting with the department head the
principal and Dr con however Margaret is
completely against the idea she asserts
that there are more experienced teachers
for this and they can't just disrespect
those teachers by replacing them with
Aaron who started teaching just 2 years
ago with this failed attempt Aaron goes
back to the class and shares the
school's decision which is clearly
unacceptable to the students despite
this she reminds them of their potential
and encourages them to do their best
following this Aaron assigns the
students with their final project
writing their Diaries in book form just
like Anne Frank Aaron believes that the
students aren't just kids in a class
anymore instead they're writers with
their own voices and own stories
according to Aaron even if nobody reads
it the book would be something to leave
behind later on Aaron compiles all the
entries and names the book as the
freedom writer's diary the following day
she is summoned for another meeting at
the board of education at the end of the
meeting the chairman permits her to
teach her kids not only in their junior
level but also in their senior years
Aaron immediately goes to her students
and shares this good news much to their
Elation the movie ends with a note that
Aaron successfully prepared numerous
high school students to graduate and
attend college subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching